[Music]
on this Sunday night heading home help
for frustrated Canadians trapped on a
cruise we're feeling a little abandoned
here Plus lifting the quarantine at CFB
Trenton blockade concerns we know our
lessons from the past what's needed to
get the trains back on track
the Brits keep a stiff upper lip during
another severe storm nature will just do
what it's going to do and
friend-to-friend
just forever indebted the life-saving
gift that's rekindled a relationship
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us hundreds of Canadians have received
the news they've been waiting days to
hear they can finally go home Ottawa has
chartered a plane to bring back to
Canada the 255 Canadians quarantined on
the diamond Princess cruise ship but
their medical journey isn't over those
passengers will now have to undergo
another two-week quarantine here at home
meanwhile the 398 Canadians currently at
CFB Trenton have received word their
quarantine will be coming to an end as
early as Friday Mike Armstrong has our
top story tonight the number of people
infected on the diamond princess is
still rising Japan announced Sunday
there are 70 more cases for a total so
far 355 for the passengers still on the
ship that's 27 days in quarantine and
Counting Sunday the u.s. started taking
healthy Americans off the ship and
they're starting to see the light at the
end of a long tunnel very soon
not yet but very soon we will be
stepping foot outside now the Canadian
government is still working on its plan
to bring Canadians home it's chartered a
plane and the operation should be this
week but we do know is where they'll be
taken this Convention Center in Cornwall
Ontario the passengers will be screened
in Japan before leaving flown to the
Trenton military base checked again and
then move to Cornwall they'll spend 14
days being monitored for symptoms
Cornwall's mayor posted a message on
Facebook Sunday saying she's heard
concerns from citizens on whether the
center is a suitable quarantine facility
it is frustrating that I don't have more
information from the federal government
that I can provide to residents you
really don't have as much detail as I
would like to have at this time not at
all a Quebec couple from the ship isn't
making the trip back Deanne and Bernama
now have tested positive one of their
daughters as they were moved this
weekend to a military base in Tokyo she
says they're in a quarantine room
together with light symptoms something
similar to a mild flu now the quarantine
in Trenton continues but they're to the
end of the tunnel
is coming into sight li zhong is with
his wife and two children he was very
happy Sunday to show off a letter he
received this morning it says the first
group that arrived could be released
this coming Friday the second group four
days later I lost you wanna go home
don't says the mood is positive people
are allowed outside to talk to each
other just not too close of course you
keep a leg of safety sense which is two
meters away there is a Canadian
permanent resident from the diamond
princess quarantine who's headed back to
North America but to the US
Spencer Ferrand bakker lives in BC but
he also has an American passport he
wanted to return to Canada but decided
because the u.s. trip was happening
first he'd take that option they'll be
doing 14 days in quarantine at a
military base in California and then
return home to Langley BC Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal the Canadian
Federation of nurses unions is calling
on Ottawa to do more to protect
frontline health care workers from
outbreaks like koban 19 the Labour
Organization says safety protocols from
the public health agency of Canada are
inadequate because they assume the virus
can't be spread through the air
they say the science hasn't confirmed
that yet and the nurses unions want the
government guidelines to include greater
care until there are a hundred percent
sure the Federation believes the current
protocols may be putting health care
workers and patients at risk it's like a
firefighter they don't know what they're
going to have when they jump into a
building so they're well protected from
head to toe when we enter a room when a
potential infectious contagious patient
we have to be protected from head to toe
because we can't be analyzing is it
airborne or droplet the federal
protocols are aligned with the World
Health Organization but the Ontario
government and the US Centers for
Disease Control have recommended higher
standards the public health agency of
Canada has not responded to a request
for comment in China
authorities say their efforts to contain
the outbreak are beginning to work the
country says just over 19
kovat 19 cases were confirmed today the
overall number of cases reported in
China is now more than 71 thousand more
than 1700 people have died in Hubei
Province where the outbreak is
concentrated millions of people have
been ordered to stay home most
businesses except those selling
essential supplies remain closed some
breaking news now out of Ottawa Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau has canceled a
planned trip tomorrow to Barbados he's
being criticized for being absent during
nationwide demonstrations in support of
an anti pipeline protest in northern BC
the blockades have caused mass
disruption to rail services across this
country and there's no sign of a
resolution anytime soon Canada's
indigenous Services Minister spoke to
global news today about what might be
next
as Ottawa tries to end the impasse is
David akin it was early evening Saturday
when Indigenous Services Minister Mark
Miller emerged from an eight-hour
meeting with leaders from the Mohawks of
the Bay of Quinte members of that first
nation have bought Aidid a vital sea and
rail line east of Belleville Ontario
since February the 7th the rule of law
is also Sunday on the West block with
Mercedes Stevenson Miller talked about
that meeting they were very suspicious
of me going in there
they thought it was perhaps a trick it
wasn't he said he was warned not to go
to the blockade but he thought that was
the wrong move this was an opportunity
to show a little bit of trust talk to
people who were very fearful standing
out there feeling targeted by the entire
country and Miller described the
situation as both volatile and
compelling we know our lessons from the
past that people can get hurt violence
here absolutely we all should be
concerned to them in addition to
supporting the wet so attend of northern
BC this Mohawk first nation has its own
reasons for protests including
outstanding land claims a continuing
boil water advisory and what it says is
not enough federal funding no one from
the First Nation or the blockade would
speak to Global News on camera about the
Miller meeting though off-camera some
say they are not optimistic of a quick
resolution Miller is one of Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau's closest
friends the two first met in high school
Miller was elected in twenty
15 to represent a downtown Montreal
riding he has served as a Canadian
Forces reservist and is a lawyer by
training they worked out and he has
recently learned to speak Mohawk all
those attributes will now be put to the
test to help solve a crisis that is
causing serious economic harm to the
country we also have to look at
ourselves as Canadians and say do we use
every peaceful method to resolve this
situation and that's the path that I
prefer it's frustrating to many I have
received many emails calls discussions
about how people are suffering the
economy suffering their fuel shortages
that are imminent and that weighs
heavily on my mind
Miller has given the Prime Minister some
recommendations though he would not say
what they were and he could not say when
or how the blockade will be lifted and
so in the meantime the blockade remains
in place and the federal cabinet will
discuss next steps early next week
Robin David akin in Ottawa thanks David
large parts of Britain are experiencing
record flooding the country's National
Weather Service has issued over 250
flood warnings for England Scotland and
Wales storm dennis has deluge the UK
bringing a month's worth of rain in just
48 hours to south wales that region has
been bearing the brunt of the country's
second severe storm in a week as
Jennifer Johnson reports the army had to
be called in
storm Dennis is roaring across Britain
thousands of homes and businesses
damaged by high winds and heavy rains
the storm described as a bombed cyclone
triggered nearly 600 flood warnings and
alerts in England alone Sunday more than
any other day on record dozens of other
warnings have been issued in places
across Wales Scotland and Northern
Ireland
authorities say residents need to
protect themselves from life-threatening
conditions we asked the community's
people who to understand the local flood
risk and to and to make take action
advising people just don't drive through
flood water don't take that chance
emergency boats have had to rescue
residents from dozens of villages as
rivers burst their banks of coercing
people to flee their homes try and keep
a level head stay keep your sense of
humor you know and do what you can do at
the end of the day nature will just do
what it's going to do to stop it
as winds create enormous waves in the
North Atlantic and North Sea the bodies
of two men have been pulled from the
water in separate searches inland army
soldiers have been deployed to try and
stop the widespread flooding I've got
guys behind you I'm filling sandbags in
doing and just putting out some flood
defences winds have reached hurricane
strength a witness posted this video
online showing a passenger plane
struggling to land at London's Heathrow
Airport hovering over the tarmac as it
fought dangerous cross winds this is the
second major storm in a week to hit
Great Britain deadly storm Sierra also
brought flooding heavy winds and more
terrifying video of planes trying to
land in England traveling by air or rail
is almost impossible now flight and
train service cancellations have
stranded thousands of travelers among
those in limbo many families trying to
leave for vacation as British schools
start their midwinter break now forced
to wait until Denis moves on Jennifer
Johnson Global News a state of emergency
has been declared in Mississippi as it
deals with some of the worst flooding
the state has seen in decades one major
cause for concern is the Pearl River in
Jackson it's been swelling from days of
heavy rain water levels have reached
close to 11 meters and the river is
predicted to continue to rise just a
half-a-meter heading into Monday many
homes in the area are already underwater
this is a historic event
it's a unprecedented in the last 35
years
we are we haven't seen flood levels like
this in the area since 1983 many people
were only given 24 hours to pack up
their belongings and leave the
government estimates more than 2400
structures could be affected by the
flooding coming up the e-cigarette
black-market and how easy it is for kids
to get their hands on these products
it's illegal to sell e-cigarettes and
vaping products to minors in Canada and
yet the devices remain popular among
teens that's because it's easy for kids
to get their hands on these products
Global Nationals Heather York's West has
been looking into the gaps that allow
the law to be broken
Brianna Ghandour says nearly everyone at
her Calgary high school vapes almost
every kid I see has one here in Alberta
you must be at least eighteen to
purchase East cigarettes or other
products but el ganador says younger
teens at her school seem to have no
problem purchasing the products both in
stores and online convenience stores
Mac's 7-eleven anywhere and some kids
sell them look at compliance in stores
in general that compliance is being less
than you would hope under Canadian law
convenience stores and vape shops must
verify a customer's age before selling
products but online proof of age varies
from site to site for example if you
wanna buy from I quote switches from
tobacco companies you know I have to
actually send a picture of my driver's
license companies like Jewel have quite
good age verification online third-party
sales sites like Facebook marketplace
and Kijiji have both banned the sale of
vaping products we put that to the test
we found no vaping products were
available for sale on Facebook but on
Kijiji there were plenty up for grabs in
a statement Kijiji says we commit
significant resources towards the
detection and Prevention of activities
that infringe our policies asking that
users let us know if they see an ad that
they think is illegal advocates say the
rules need to be better enforced across
the board we'd like to see more
inspections of stores on a regular basis
test shoppers should be used to ensure
that there are high levels of compliance
and the enforcement should be parallel
to what we see on tobacco health Canada
says it regularly inspects retailers
including those online for compliance
visiting 3,000 stores in the last six
months alone but despite those efforts
from algún doors perspective
cigarettes haven't become any more
difficult to get everyone has one
everyone Heather Erik's West Global News
Calgary in Costa Rica police seized five
point eight tons of cocaine this weekend
the biggest drug bust in that country's
history the drugs were found in over 200
suitcases inside a shipping container
bound for the Netherlands authorities
say they were being smuggled under the
guise of a shipment of ornamental
flowers one suspect a 46 year old man
has been arrested the United Nations is
calling on world powers to stop
violating an arms embargo aimed at
curbing a bloody civil war in Libya the
UN's deputy special envoy for Libya
spoke out about the problem after
meeting today with foreign ministers in
Munich she says several countries
backing rival factions in Libya have
repeatedly violated the UN backed
embargo she called for them to be held
to account I think on numerous occasions
the arms embargo has become a joke and
so it you know we all really need to
step up here Libya is awash and weaponry
and now advanced weaponry and that's
very dangerous for regional peace and
security not to mention international
peace and security
Libya has been in turmoil since 2011
when a civil war led to the downfall and
death of dictator Muammar Qaddafi
countries with interests in the war
including Turkey and the United Arab
Emirates renewed a pledge today to
uphold the arms embargo still ahead a
new way for investors to stake their
claim in the art world for a fraction of
the cost for anyone interested in owning
a piece of high-priced
art for a fraction of the cost it may be
possible a New York company is buying
artwork and then selling shares in it to
its customers there's profit potential
but it isn't limited to art in the past
few years these fractional ownership
structures have sprung up for vintage
cars racehorses and comic books
Ross Lorde reports the art world is full
of high priced products this is an 1881
landscape by Claude Monet
one of our one of our favorite offerings
that's available now so this is an
important seven million dollar painting
that were that we're offering to
investors as of recently don't have
seven million bucks kicking around not
necessary not anymore a New York startup
is billing itself as the first company
that allows anyone to invest in
multi-million dollar paintings for as
little as $1,000 American we have thirty
six thousand investors signed up today
so investors range from from very small
investors who are in college to large
investors that are that are viewing this
as a serious allocation of a portfolio
and I shall sell it then I will bring
the hammer down at one hundred and
thirty nine million dollars when the
company sells the paintings to a
collector it shares profits with its
clients if you're thinking there must be
a catch there is masterworks charges 1.5
percent per year and it takes 20% of
future profits and like any investing
there's always the chance of betting on
a losing proposition so you do have that
appreciation but you also have the risk
of losing all your money right if you
buy this painting for a million dollars
and then ten years later they want to
sell them they only could sell it for
seven hundred forty you can still lose
money on it it's a model of it could
prove successful not just in the US but
potentially in Canada too according to
the most recent numbers from Statistics
Canada the Canadian auction market for
paintings and other visual arts was
already worth a staggering seven hundred
seventy six million dollars in 2016 a
42% increase from 2015 our art shares a
new way to diversify investments or a
risky venture in a market that's far
from guaranteed the choice is in the eye
of the beholder
Ross Lord global news up next the
Canadian baseball world mourns the loss
of a Blue Jays legend
[Applause]
the Toronto Blue Jays are mourning the
loss of one of their greats Tony
Fernandes a five-time all-star and one
of their best ever infielders has died
at the age of 57 born in the Dominican
Republic Fernandes was signed by the
Jays in 1979 when he was 17 he played 12
seasons with them including in 1993 when
they won the World Series in a statement
on Twitter the Jays described Fernandes
as one of our club's most celebrated and
respected players who left an equally
indelible mark in the hearts of a
generation of fans family hasn't
confirmed how Fernandez died but he had
long struggled with kidney problems over
the last few weeks he was reportedly in
hospital due to complications from
kidney disease kidney disease is on the
rise in Canada and so is the demand for
organ donations according to the latest
data from the canadian organ replacement
register there were over 1,700 kidney
transplants in 2018 in that same year
over 3,000 people were still on the wait
list and the average wait time for a
transplant is four years but this week
one man is finally getting the gift of
life and it's all thanks to friendship
Stephan Gillis and Michael Teigen spend
a lot of time together and they're just
hours away from sharing a different kind
of bond one is giving the other a kidney
I know it's not a cure it's a treatment
but it's a huge treatment to get me out
of the dialysis chair Gillis has a rare
disease that attacked both his kidneys
on top of having Crohn's disease
what yeah last April Tegan a friend
Gillis hadn't seen in a decade surprised
him with the promise of his kidney
Gillis has gone through surgeries to
prep him for the transplant while
enduring dialysis what has been the
hardest part going through what you've
had to go through or the anticipation of
this surgery mentally it's it's really
difficult all this attention has been
overwhelming just the whole experience
also just trying to understand you know
how amazing Michael is for doing this
and knowing that there's other people in
need it's not just me and but I'm the
one that's getting it it's hard to
accept sometimes so sometimes comes with
a little bit of guilt because you know
there's other people that need help 10
months later they're on track for
surgery whereas Tegan calls it a kidney
relocation was there ever a moment when
you thought I can't do this absolutely
not
no nothing more to say it's been full
steam the whole time
studies show that those who received
living organs have longer functioning
kidneys but it's not easy to be that
person who steps up I always have a so
much respect for people coming forward
as donors it's it's just an incredible
thing to do and it's a incredible gift
to give and sacrifice to me Teagan has
never spent time in a hospital or
undergone any surgery but he's prepared
for any risks I'm a little nervous but
more more just excited to to help to
make this happen there have been
countless tests and counseling sessions
now they're more than ready for the
surgery and along the way there's been a
newfound friendship well I'm kind of at
his bidding for the rest of his life
because I'm just forever indebted he's a
hero
and in a great example for others and
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
downtown Vancouver thank you for
watching good night
[Music]